hey you what man you have you been
practice I know your fingers are really
long welcome back second World Tour
finest see play does that either way
guys it has been some crazy matches so
far today I've been sitting out in the
crowd with you guys and I'm still a
little windy right now for some of the
matches the first match out of the day I
almost killed sick man
you gave me a lot of time massages on my
left side and I'm actually very [ __ ]
suicides yeah you ever worked on this
idea I mean this besides a little bit
tighten this one's really loosey-goosey
well I tell you what these players may
not be too loose cuz it's definitely too
tight right now to call they've been so
many close sets you can see right here
group a is an example of how close this
can be this is world caliber talent you
guys are looking at Group B just the
same look at double coming out with the
for older leave the set and make it out
of Group B as well and Annie can just
barely barely squeezing it out making it
into that top eight as well you can see
in group 8 we got knee and all sign but
group C is comprised of two world
champions
I'm not even ranked you as well we got
allowed in there the LCQ winner
representing pakistan and of course JD
CR but up on the stage you see Bulow
versus st. in the RPS the mind game
begins now and you already saw him shoot
scissors with the gun yeah yeah the
Korean the Korean scissors what they
used to do this thing something like
that shoutouts the st. man this year
recently picked up by gg yeah he's been
doing actually you know this this year
has definitely been kind of the most
shaky year he's had right he's always
been a staple in the finals you know
even winning a couple years back right
you want to he did he did one Evo and
the world yep
but uh you know this year hasn't been
his best you know he struggled to even
secure his spot you know he was on the
he was on the the border right he's 19th
place in entire time for a long time
yeah Dreamhack Atlanta was a huge
tournament for him and he even though he
don't even know if he made point from
that tournament he managed to get keep
at least enough
look I'm save his spot one thing that
has been consistent is his cool hairdos
man he's
went from the short to the long the old
boy and now he's like you know
collective God and I like what we're
seeing from I mean this year has
definitely been one of those things
where I've been looking at saying I'm
like where are you gonna fall when it
comes down to the end of this right what
are you where are you going to be when
this is done and we get to the finals
this year and look at them still making
the top of a still getting enough points
but let's talk about his opponent who
didn't have too many choices in the
matter represent Pakistan Bulow this
dude came out won the LCQ a crazy set
versus okay that LCQ was actually
ridiculous I mean there's no ticking LCQ
does that's not ridiculous but the fact
that bulow came out here takes the takes
the W from the LCQ and makes the top
eight appearance you know he saw we saw
his Akuma and you know a lot of people
were like he's an Akuma player yeah I
but he's like guys that I remember I'm
I'm a Brian play I've been a Brian man
for a long time and he used that Brian
to actually seal the set and steal a lot
of sets actually never really use Akuma
all that much he doesn't even and he
plays a very unconventional Brian like
he does not do things that we see
regular Brian's do but spag was telling
me he was like you know this is the most
established a tournament established
player in Pakistan Europe it's below
he's been playing for that long that's
why his Brian is the character of choice
Akuma is the secondary Akuma is the the
counter right that's what I do it for
either that your reason for playing yeah
just the count of people that don't know
what I'm doing it's the best it's the
best kind of strategy but it looks like
they're gonna be logging into the
characters you know we don't see we you
know we saw a saint early on in Tekken
slice been messing around with different
characters other than jack we saw we we
saw him play Bob for a little bit but
you know he's always been a Jack mean
yeah in this game because there's no
game you he definitely pulled out of
Devil Jim's at one of these stops on a
ticket world to her actually never like
I think it was like a CEO thing and I'm
like man this dude is really reaching to
understand what happened right now look
like season three threw everybody up I
mean season two three like that
transitional phase actually made a
difference in like the tournament right
right
but you see you we're gonna have the law
versus st. and did see Michael house
locked into the brine which you know
most Brian players would say this is a
great matchup for I mean yeah look the
fact is they like Jack can't move around
that well Brian has a bunch of tracking
moves you got to respect the spacing no
matter what
there we go game number one group C play
is gonna be below vs st. man I love
saying that guy's name Oh Anne this
arena is gonna be mad small does he have
the taunt jet up pistol and we haven't
seen any icon shut up if you didn't even
hit a few you know little parts here and
there but you didn't even give me
opportunities form you know it Kate
played a very solid game yesterday but
unfortunately he didn't he wasn't able
to punch it out against Palau and just
to explain to you guys this group C play
whoever has the two highest players with
the best records will be making to that
top eight and they will be placed up
there but that's what they're playing
for first round first blood same yeah
that was a great were punished
difference a notice think that he was
gonna be out of range for the punish and
got his own punish of his own nice tries
to go for the hook pull out just a
little bit out of range though the
punches the Lisa Simpson I'm gonna walk
toward you swinging my arm look at st.
just holding his ground low parry okay
and the educator yes it was Oh try to
hit him with the robot recline are not
gonna work that's a very hard move the
part is actually a lot of jack players
like to use that at the wall just
because of the push back it'll keep them
a little bit out of range and if it hits
obviously he gets a lost boy and he
punished it was for for two on top of it
and that's not easy to do out of blocks
down put this wall though you did into
it put your shoulder into it yeah great
choice there's a not only give me the
throw but also give me the hearts of amp
a lot not block to the extension
horrible oh nice call all right they're
going for the low fee he can definitely
get the wall if he plays his right huh
yes let me see them knees yeah catch it
Rogers brought up but nobody they train
right there nice for to so we're gonna
hit confront back we're back oh you're
dead this is a st. special yeah all
you get to crazy you get to antsy he'll
eat the hit hit you at the range aren't
bunch of damage but he's still in
trouble the backpack for it didn't work
oh my gosh
[Applause]
what a first game from st. those first
two rounds and dominate but that last
one he said you know what we'll start
off with this rage aren't and we'll end
it with the throw I love how I love how
Jack pushes himself after he hit you
with the tone stone he's like yeah like
slide it out from under you like he was
hiding under the bed so he's like get
off alright here we go oh wow
thinking about it that was a pretty
clean three rounds right there yes I
mean the last one was the closest he had
obviously but that ray job was the
beginning of the end for him he goes to
rematch pretty quickly you know he's
definitely one of those guys that really
takes his time between every game oh you
win or lose it feels like I mean he's
one of those players and we've seen it
before and plenty other games as well as
techni he like he prax his brains like
what did I do
what do I need to change and he's
already made some changes looking like
this round is looking a lot better
already
um let me see doing looking good looking
good already
adjustments seem to have been made not
even any buds no moving beats the spring
didn't get a launch Sun blocked it down
for you guys like 17 machine-gun punches
and they were all blocked there's still
that last war which is all that mattered
really you won 2-1 right there didn't
get the counter hit though orbital once
again
that's how the last round started he's
doing it again yeah that was a max range
orbital as well hitting the jab that's
cheap oh nice - one can get the wall
again never think about this small stage
bro you got to be careful back one plot
try it again all nice st. just a little
bit on another orbital he's three for
three on them bad boys the this match is
definitely looking a little different
however the cross chop oh oh wait a
minute Bulow already making me adjust
yeah great job here to pull out I mean
it's basically like you said the
orbitals we're starting off the entire
match mode
I said he's got to be careful and those
down for two is a definitely have been
getting him in trouble
oh why wives in one wait a minute wall
every round he starts the match with a
wall combo peak the images will our
chocolate hot soccer came out and just
three rounds straight in a perfect to go
Pakistan out here yeah I hear y'all out
there you don't have to yell anymore
I've seen the country you guys are nice
okay look what you won doing gonna
destructed the neck Saints like I got to
get another haircut but hey say first
came out what would that be that big
haircut right with the perm yeah I was
all about this yeah go to it he said
there was an accident and then he kept
talking with it the entire year I wasn't
aware that was like you like it
it was accident I mean that cool go tell
your friend st. the Korean guy I'm nice
baby all right artists no fault here for
saying oh yeah lots of space lots of
space one thing I don't think a lot of
people like to point out about saying
like he controls the pace by spacing
like he uses the clock but Morse was
about annoying you with the space all
right a little more respect being played
right now of course this is two out of
three they're trying to get the best
record out of their group and this is no
even good none of these groups are easy
it's crazy
blow very nice now back to out there huh
takes the okie instead I like the little
check right there with a down 4-1 make
them respect it while rising to just to
be sure
mohnish I like make sure any it swag
that's my little brother go we drop the
combo hatchet oho look at the sliver the
fingernail link a life affair still see
the dirt under that bad boy all right -
do it again
cut that do it again don't work don't do
it anymore
all come to town at this time all right
good sergeant
I'm saying nice oh wow and wolf tail oh
that was a great job that full of just
kind of just
sweet double hatchet oh he tried to do
it again misses the four four four
there's the whole parry manifold out
what happened that first ten right
that's lucky racks his brain he punishes
himself he's like brain we need to do
better and he's doing a lot better get
real close to closing out this scent
first the two like I said before the
next hit will do a cross chop not gonna
work this time try to go for the
tombstone that state has no healthier
okay all right down for two only a real
bastard only a real master Annie spins
the rage Arthas gonna give me some time
to think
ah shells everywhere oh nice back to 25
seconds it's still very closely that we
could do this do my chair my chair Phil
we need things with wheels back here
okay yeah I guess you just slightly onto
the stage all right I just oh my god man
oh my god oh yeah Oh st. trying to make
something happen
Wow right there at the helm of victory
and just not able to close out - all
right about standing for - one back one
oh damn it's on the side of a while
drawing first blood in this group see
play versus st. and what happened to
that first game you know it feels like
you know even yesterday to it that I'll
seek you right Palau even though he won
it felt like he wasn't playing up to
like his own standard I feel like you
know a little bit sloppy you know having
a few drops definitely had a lot of
crucial drops in this game as well but
signs of a strong player man supid at
those are really good signs of a strong
player I mean we saw the Lau it just
sounded like mentally strong he is that
LCQ was nothing to sneeze it I feel like
we say this every time there's a second
tournament but this is definitely the
hardest second tournament let's take a
look at Group C Bulow like I said
getting first blood and you can tell by
the other standings right that two three
range for if you're lucky is gonna be
the magic number you're trying to hit
you well you definitely want to make
sure you stay in the winners side of
things and we got our next match already
up on the stage is gonna be JD CR versus
Chickering yeah you know JD's y'all
remember that year he was a dominant
player but one title he hasn't won you
know he's one of Evo he has never won a
type of World Tour Finals
he's getting a lot closer and I believe
we got some words from mr. J DCR before
we get into this next match let's take a
look I would like to play non THC
characters or non 2d characters such as
Akuma keys because because we see them
quite often during you know this this
year during the GWT GWT pets so you know
I want to play with or against the
Tekken characters Wow funny
you're fighting chicken and this guy
plays nine hours straight with all those
characters you just sit so it's cool you
got you wish Chickering one of those
guys who definitely plays a lot uh one
of the players we've been looking at all
year actually who's always been a
consistent threat his geese is super
strong has a Jin as well I've definitely
seen him play Akuma I mean he's just a
strong player cross support but jec are
we've seen him year in and year out do
ridiculous things in the taking world
toward no matter what yeah you know
chicken at one point would probably be
considered one of the strongest players
if not the strongest player from Japan
you know representing that western Japan
style
I'm sure Obama has a clever nickname for
chicken in like some of the plays like
the shield of Osaka maybe chicken ends
like the the sword of Fukuoka or
something that'll I'm not sure but got
the D&D title don't Dec what you're
telling me right invite me to a game say
Jim I know I'm slacking but I'll be
there soon I'm gonna learn the ways of
D&D in Japan with Chickering in Majin
Obama I've survived it Obama got a
wizard hat somewhere a wizard do Rick we
came along he simply have that that is
100% facts
oh man alright JD co-operative we're
going into it geese vs. dragon oh here
we going this is exactly what I was
talking about man chicken is one of the
geese is a lot of people feared at the
throughout the entire year of the Tekken
World Tour in the later half chicken not
showing
so much but still a threat yeah you know
it's definitely a lot of people a lot of
geese players right when season 3 came
out they saw all the nurses thinking
okay you know what I can't play this
character anymore he's not as strong let
me know if you saw Chitra play a lot of
gin early on play he's some cookies I
mean he's still very strong and it's
definitely his best characterize at this
moment and like if you think about it
right like him having those extra care
all pull all those Kirk's or considered
super strong I'm in the back pocket
Steele and remember we don't even have a
gin in this in the group way at this
point it would be Fiji he could also be
theater she was right exactly but you
have JDC are speaking of the Mishima you
know everybody likes to get that chance
with a GOG but he's starting off with
dragon off this time around something oh
that's definitely not JDC our life let's
play a game of Clue it was the butler in
the cupboard you see how he's holding it
he just stands there with his hands down
like yeah I did that it's like he's
holding a sledgehammer and it just stuck
in the ground
oh you can see Chickering kind of
pushing till there wall already that's
what got him in trouble last time yeah
for for it does have that meter on lock
no CPM decides to use it right now it
just hold on to it
hold down two or one plus two he's
definitely gonna get the wall and a lot
of media on top of top stock to use the
meeting kindergarten until guaranteed
with the super fund instead perfect
right saves the meter has two meters on
deck for these next two rounds
not what you decide to make your bed
noise that's all I'm here with the SOG
that master the loan yeah you got to be
careful now yeah three meters any launch
Rico Tempe death like this doesn't even
use the rest of the evening
I don't know definitely need you
shouldn't use it I wouldn't do this
press the JDC are spins the blue stuff
got the jab keep it with check
now JDC our download in Brown's here but
so first game you heard how excited he
wants to play against TV he likes the
beaters you guys are complaining JDC are
trying to fight it down for two
oh nice sidestep on the jab right there
chicken is being super offensive got him
in trouble there's the counter that nice
amount of defecation get off of me bro
he's got this jacket clean Oh interrupt
with a jab I like the strings right
there to stop the chicken rep from
moving around
JDC are with the lead right now
quick walk expensive eater another stock
that gets the to Chancellor went to the
for one this can definitely be it no
dropp got I've seen you do it a million
times
deadly brave usual deadly rain stay down
maggot sick
so JD sir got his wish
got the plague if two keys and I was
thinking about this saintly another
thing that we were just talking about
I'm musician took full advantage of it
right the state select is pivotal gives
you more time to think on top of it
might give you a small advantage when it
comes to the combos depending on your
character and place now yeah JD's
thinking real hard about this and he
starts to go to a wall stage and she
couldn't just gives a thumbs up the
Japanese crowd here today has been wild
oh yeah that look have you seen shooty
shooty 'he's been going crazy all i've
seen nothing but shooty teeth in the
crowd different points in the arena i'm
like we're a shootie there he is
see the reflection off his glasses and
his cheap yeah he's always smiling
that's the best part about that man yeah
but this japanese crowd you know the one
thing about is that all for japanese
players all went into different pools
yeah it's definitely true so so japan
got a lots of root for here and they
know obviously they got double in the
top a finally double is ridiculous the
for all but here we go-oh running to get
a little more plate with those downforce
first one we've seen but it looks pretty
obvious what do you want to start well
for
down one down to county had launcher
anymore I like that where he checks
missus the Perry he's like I left my
keys in the house crap just locked
myself out of my car down to finishes
the string yo he's in trouble his backs
to this wall JD see I need to do
something nice punished check around in
control
he's got the red highlights on that rage
is right there twenty seconds left on
the clock
Janey's he are taking his time yeah
beautiful whip on his take on it just
enough damage to didn't risk it with
anything you know something slower this
one for the same night walk no meter
needed stand up die to use spent the
meter there a ton of damage but he's
still got a nice chunk there nice party
chef JD JD doesn't seem like frazzled at
all he doesn't seem like this is making
him up too uncomfortable but he's
playing his game yeah solid give your
jaggon all player you have to even if
you can sidestep you have to still use
it because it's a core move and he's got
two bars on top of 30 seconds left on
the clock JDC are life looking pretty
low transition it to the 4:3 after the
down three gets a little chip damage
nice block side switch that's good
that's perfect job there 0.3 down to
again tap in the shoes oh wow that's at
the laid on that counter hit string man
three coming from chick ramp
nice job they're tied up one one here
oopsie
once again just facing pushing to that
wall once again reversal like that
nice what a block catching up side
walking my keys where's my wallet drop
my phone low pair the shoulder well
right no Mikey with the keys of the
shoes on the ground Wow Oh punished JDC
on match point right now game number two
her sticker
yeah max mode here you know yes two
meters still you use that you Maximo
dental you want plate chicken that's
been holding on to the meter quite a
quite a bit yeah you've been saying it
to he's been holding on to that meter
looking for the right time to pull the
trigger on so that's good too you know
what that damage output is pretty hot
nice punish again on the down - yeah I
mean listen if you can win in around
without spinner meter then that's by two
wins excuse wait till you get to that
last round another reversal not letting
them get away with that I don't know
they're punished nice running one oh how
many times I received back this week
I've been the bane of your existence
I feel like every time your Oh God stop
on them oh the Dell - oh my god
Matt JD's you're clutching to that
extreme just died with three boys yo did
you see how dragging off dust off his
jacket he was like you get away from me
you got I got stuff to do a very JDC our
attitude all the secret nice bottle sip
Oh who downloaded who that's then the
question they both drank the water at
the same time who downloaded who won
fight oh oh you got a crowd getting into
it yo yo Japan are you guys with Chikara
and make some noise out there
what about my boy JDC oh you guys with
Jackie's here alright okay I got I got
you ain't gotta tell me twice
yeah man it's the deadly rave not that
mild damage or evoke a particularly
great I've been there before
Oh down for 120 oh my god how many
slopes Lobos told you man as soon as you
stepped in the buildin the slo-moes wind
up like 200% it's part of my special
ability it's my course yeah man give you
more time to attack okay great break
sidewalk tries to get to launch over the
down for to it nice understand stages
even I'm surprised
usually nobody's plays they always go to
the Kisa the Howard estate a really slow
paced game right here you can see JD
Sierra once again just calm cool
collected yeah up for four whole night
activation right there from the fort one
goes in a Maxima only one bar no 20
seconds left on the clock life lead in
favor of Chickering though Galton once
again
oh and this is the final match of the
samurai 13 seconds left on the clock
raised on the side of Dragon often this
Jamie's gone whoa it's a whuppin one one
is will and we've been seeing a lot of
these players doing that today
and that's the first time I feel like
it's worked out jab me that DX air
fireball if it hits and you'd land fast
enough you did it going up to the ground
you can actually comp off of it that
Mike that one will find a bit of compost
Oh autumn swinging once again down for
canceled into reppuken JD start not lady
trying to fight his way off this walk
he's keeping him pressured they're not
letting him believe she's gonna fight it
back though 12 more wounds band at four
set point
JDC oh yeah close close set here chicken
right exhales a little bit all right no
meter spit stand up die Oh ball down for
two okay you know that's something
ginger just goes through everything once
in a while just like I listen I got to
stop
what a feint there JDC ah let me get off
of me
DS player you posed to be here I mean
you're cool but you're not supposed to
be in my game bro JDC are 100 right now
in this group play this is good this is
good
yes sir every we got three Koreans in
this pool oh it walks off like get off
of me I love it I love it meter meter
I don't know stinking meter sit at the
bottom of the screen what is this máximo
well look that's gonna put on a jig ECR
up one Oh in this group play you're
gonna take one more look at the bracket
so far and like we said you can use it
as a comparison look that's the the
winning record you want going into it
you can check out Group a group B one O
across the board a couple of own ones
but we got ranked you amplify
ranked you coming up last year's twt
champion ranked you up on the stage
right now with a new swanky hairdo I'm a
fan daddy's going up against genuine
gaming safe and you know one of the
things about rain she was that what kind
of like last year no one's talking about
him even this year he is the returning
champion right he's defending reigning
champion undisputed whatever you want to
say any word that goes before or after
champion I don't usually know but no
one's talking about it I think it's
crazy because like you said he's the
returning twt champion and people just
kind of forgot about him being here 1 2
is just the fact that like I feel like
that's the same thing that happened less
right it's almost the exact same thing
but I feel like it's easy when there's
so many top caliber players here and the
twt finals right there's so many other
players you can look at you had the
Arslan a - you had like me you got
anakin representing the United States
you got shadow in there as well kagome's
there's so many great names that you had
to look at it's not easy but it's still
possible to overlook how strong of a
player the rancher is yeah you know the
one thing about you right you this year
however is that we
the way less of the of the Panda you
know we've seen a lot more Julie a lot
more Katerina even even lucky Chloe
every now mean I mean the Julia to like
I don't know where he's pulling out
these characters I mean I say out of
nowhere but he's definitely mentioned it
before but here we go
Saint back up on the stage he's gonna be
going up against Rancho and it's once
again two out of three
every match is going to count we got to
keep track of who's gonna win these
rounds cuz we might have a tie you saw
what happened earlier but here we go the
julia is the character of choice round
one interesting choice here from rain
truth not even thinking about it just
went straight to Julia and you know
Ashly I really like you to do it you
know he's been playing with Julia quite
a bit recently you know we see him a lot
in fighting Tuesday's out of Japan and
he was like the reigning champ there for
Wow oh okay this is not good he's
definitely to get the wall with this
julius ball carries some of the best in
the game damage not too bad either her
damage is crazy and her her wall carry
is insane like you said she's one of the
one of the more risky characters but her
damage output is crazy high but she's
also you know very punishable on a lot
of her things so you have to be a little
bit more you know safe when you try to
play her or else you can't get blown up
but you definitely have to you know be a
little careful but you got to be risk
you got to make take some risk with her
if you want to get that big damage Wow
nice competent everything even
guaranteed compensation good attack in
st. is in trouble right now he was
already down a sick so he wants to take
this victory
jackhammer once again go home man the
right ears beginning away with that and
he's always he's been doing it for quite
some time too I've been watching him at
Friday Tuesday he does it just the same
shredder kicks right out of the gate
gets the walls filled big boy combo
lifely in favor of Ranger
Saint is in a lot of trouble we've seen
him make these comebacks before oh the
tree did die yeah that was great with
what is different right you and I think
realistically in this entire match right
it's felt like branch ooh in the mid
range has been dominating the match
right because he just uses the dashboard
uses downpour to into the you know the -
into maybe the lower the mid and party
crashers well yeah he does he uses party
crasher just to start the office see how
you react you might want to size stuff
and he just reacts accordingly I feel
like his gameplay is so set he's like
look if you do this I got this he he
knows what he's doing in his care yeah
you know that's normally word you'd like
to see sane right st. as a jack plane he
likes to stay in that mid-range try to
catch you running in but French who just
seems to be getting it to you you know
way quicker and look at that weird look
he just gave us it's the hair he's
getting all evil we're not using a band
right now I love those pictures that
they have to take when when they pose
for winning or losing they look so sweet
right I've seen your Twitter you've been
hosting like victories
yeah the Bob are we seeing the Bobby's
he's definitely thinking about doing you
know I'm a big fan of Saints Bob he's
been pulling out a lot more recently in
tournament and I see he's really really
thinking about it he gets movement back
on his side I feel like you have your
easier time tracking Julia at this point
because he has you know wave - movement
this is good yeah
and definitely just switches up the
styles right maybe he's gonna be more
you know like aggressive with the jabs
with the with the one for is with the
one one twos down forward ones even I
want to see what he's gonna do to stop
this neutral I want I'm interested to
see you
that outfit is horrendous we're yeah
where'd you buy that vest that vest was
terrible
oh my god
oh not close enough to get the combo
right after it call some shred a nice
punch and look at weighing this up close
game she's getting a lot more
comfortable down four to five this mark
big damage on the wall down for one once
again and already a change in the speed
of things yes sir
st. looking really good here now
you said he's been getting away with it
he's definitely been abusing trader King
steel can I get a combo and he's gonna
get the wall on top of you
steel damage Wow no kind of magic damage
problem for that look and range you just
holding his ground when it comes to this
defense we talked about Saint just
standing in a bunch of these situations
but it has not gotten a meaty grandma
that's gonna be the route rain to
stealing that round round four round in
this second game right now
Wow before June 3 out of nowhere that
was very punishable right she was ready
to punish that easily for lingerie hey
what's the damn big damage on the wall
50 I won't add never thirty I won't have
and it feels like this entire said it's
been a fight he's back you know with her
he's back even to the wall the entire
set it feels like his dude
Saint isn't a lot of trouble East he's
in danger of going down only to in this
booth play we have not seen many players
make it out Jamie yeah very is very
close in the last group with red with a
Cocola but still you know you don't want
to put yourself in that position right
you want to say you don't want to be
because you have to rely on other
players helping you out counter hit and
you had no homies at the pool I mean
he's got a home but there are enemies
now
one backpack for 30 seconds left on the
clock st. in trouble right now this is
set point for rank qu first game here in
this group seats a party crasher once
again is just up using that range Ranchi
- all over sync yeah great used to the
party crash at their elbow elbow elbow
finally caught Saint Duncan or moving
and ranch you now look good
yeah range was starting off early comes
out my happy you saw him look at the
camera first he didn't look what you
ain't he didn't look comfortable but now
he's looking a lot more comfortable cool
hairdo as well st. in trouble though
he's down old to like we said before
we've seen him in that other group play
play you don't want to be there
especially now these guys are way too
good to let them get in a two-game lead
where you're fighting from the bottom
and of course you still have JDC on you
still have Bulow in the same pool and
it's not gonna be easy at all yeah I
mean you can't look at these poisoned oh
yeah this is easy for a and B plan no no
it is no easy matches anywhere feels
like everybody has been asking me all
year to like yo man who do you think is
gonna win and who did lose is I'm like
what kind of crazy question is that like
you can't actually answer that question
if you've been following tech and you
know you got a favorite and then this
anything can happen that's it I mean
most people would be points people would
have said arson ass right yep
oh that's definitely people but I tell
you it was random people walking to me
up on the street I'm like y'all can I
get a Red Bull you heard about this
Arslan - guy I'm like damn yeah I know
who he is nice but it'll see him in
Bangkok it's really good you know but
here we go below allows up on stage next
with chiku Tin we're gonna have a
Pakistan vs. Japan match and you know it
feels like the LCQ yesterday outside the
ball off the Pakistani players seem
touch a little bit of a struggle against
Japan yeah we also uh one of the things
about that is people don't know about
the clashing of the styles from every
region right yeah but let's get a little
bit more from Chickering let's hear some
words from
kuku Mathur ki Fateh Stan essentially
Marchetti maintenant emote upon the
master sense anemic et maintenant from a
study particle what prevents to our
sanitation marketer endemic assistance
in Geneva multiple cuts data retention
what Pakistan has done to the Tekken
scene everybody wants to play Tekken out
like look I gotta go to Pakistan to beat
everybody up he bought a ticket and went
to Pakistan just to show up and shout
outs to Palau for being that you know
that chauffeur that that help I said the
show friend
to show him around Pakistan excuse me
good driver ya know but like I saw like
the video and how he was like super
receptive met him at the airport all the
players were there and definitely helped
him out so like shout out stuff allow
for that I mean he came out got the LCQ
victory but this is chicken we're
talking about chicken wants revenge but
how do you stop somebody who has so much
experience in geese matchups oh yeah the
pepper chicken it was the first person
Jeep actually traveled to Pakistan he
was true you know he can practiced up
big there it I did it do well it's a
sweater like that alright guys if you
guys like below make some noise out
there
yo Japan you like Chikara and make some
noise oh it's pretty split it's actually
pretty split out there oh yes so open
stage Jun Masterman is gonna benefit
probably more so trigger engines because
this is a damaged in that and the open
is so good Oh tried to go for the Perry
we came for the lone not gonna work out
pull out we saw him in that first game
make a crazy turnaround vs st. Mary in
the second round and he's already
looking good yeah cheering you know he's
got to the Perry's a few times if they
have not worked out in his favor at all
he had this infini stage I'm I'm
interested to see how this works out
Bilal likes going on for that Okies
we'll see oh nice Perry gets the Mach
breaker after another thing I've noticed
about bilasa he do all those machine gun
punches oh yeah okay I understand from
jiggidy thing I like the Hokie option
just lay there let him with Wow four
okay twenty seconds left on the clock
Chikara in a rage nah bro
we got how to use this rage at all no no
one Yap - sandy - look at that
six seconds left she couldn't move to
come back there man every round has been
going down to the like basically the
last ten seconds Oh
respect
so I'm back here bro you're up there I
had no idea
hey you know you could have Maximo that
night probably got a full table or I
just got a little bitter over here will
ya get off me let's go break I caught
with the porter silverback - for a nice
kid for an informal out to one-up fight
oh yeah that's what I'm talking about
how did she get approached this batch
will be poaching like this steve-o in
the town more did I beat this right yeah
he wanted to get that out of him cuz he
knew he was gonna try to hit him on the
counter here playing it slow here you
can it so close to eat input another
genre that activated to max moly check
around rip the reef look at the damage
yes another beauty too that didn't last
time uh shoot done yet how much you need
a shoot I'm all huh
Wow the max load canceled but it did not
take that's country kill this chief we
need that we need to revisit there
that's cheap that's fine that's
perfectly fine so Anthony doing those
those legs chicken we moving around a
little more like a machine gun blow you
were talking about it loves that booth
he makes the throw the 1+2 No Deal
all right you meters now here particular
how we use it if at all look at those
quick size we've seen him go for the
sides they have two-for-one cancel or
there's there's that maximum cancel do
you have one part though last match of
this for last round of this first match
that was a crazy good points on that
with orbital you need a whopping three
nice two down four units for the matte
smoke cancel lots of blocks done
instantly pulls the trigger on that
Chickering takes the first game but wow
it looks like he's having fun of it that
even racket is brainy but you know what
this is what I'm here for
yeah and we see mr. right chicken after
his uh is a time to Pakistan you know
obviously you didn't do too hot there
right but you don't go there to like oh
yeah I'm gonna go then you know just
beat up everyone right you go in there
because you know that that's a strong
place and you want to practice against
the best and he took it he took his else
put it right after that right he ended
up playing against I believe I watched
honey in the next tournament and he
actually defeated him man's and that's
another thing I'm really interested to
see in Pakistan I want to know the
stories I'm gonna know the Lord right I
want to go to one of these turn them and
see how they play against each other see
how that unfolds give us a little more
story to this Pakistan fighting game
scene this Tekken scene but regardless
blough represent quite well but he's in
trouble right now but you know he goes
the Machine my daughter here probably
good stage for both players but you know
obviously I think Bulow loves to use the
walls here haven't seen him used to
taunt too often but he knew i
realistically just hasn't had the
opportunity to i mean we saw him
yesterday and
it is very different than typical Brian
cleaners right yeah but the application
is still there we know he knows about it
so you never know you still got to be at
least a little bit leery of it all right
here we go Game two in this set right
now Palau horse nickering yeah this is a
big big game here for both players
because the Laos has 100 cheeping it's
down to 0 1 so when here would tie them
both up in records and also get both of
them you know give chicken in at least a
good shot in fall of my ball back - to
the side steps when you break the curl
top of it back one this time he has
walls oh so this can be a lot more
dangerous on both sides accident they
hold their heat combo on the side step 3
- Kim tries to go for the running 1 on
the follow-up pull out feeling rage with
she Gumbel a bunch of damage all the
patients they're gone and you just you
felt the bed like he wanted the duck
wait here it's too scary scary oh nice
catches them out of the air almost had a
float watch Perry again slapped so hard
oh man it's his move
that is his move that block you know his
uh his adaptation has been so great this
over his face it's smoking he's like
I've given him a cigarette it's already
went to right the spark I got you bro no
problem good punish it for take it in
four down two rounds here play while
caught up moving it with that hole with
that what you said - sorry big damage
taking the damp it's time get away from
me chicken trying to steal this round
back steal this game back Bulow up to
round right now in the second game Oh
smooth then it's his move Oh
from all while champ them out of the
orbital this time there we go I'm stayin
alive in this game here this would be a
big game to because winning 2:0 is a lot
better than winning 2-1 as odd as it
sounds
and then normal to double elimination
tournament we would say like oh yeah to
one or two so it doesn't matter right
but in this round robin format where
game differential actually matters a to
warrant is a little bit worse than a 2-0
yeah you definitely trying to eat you
want to play as flawlessly as possible
look at this this oh my god chicken it
now with the huge like wheat here and
stealing back this game pulao is in
trouble
Chickering is on set point hearing who
play haha get off of me get throw break
that's the ticket it down for one that
long range a from he's definitely been
happening I'm sure he has meter not
gonna spend it though he definitely just
got it on that to in the 4-1 Oh Angie
mr. soccer kick oh wow lawd
take the okie yeah and she could it has
one meter to work with you two great
spot for him right now
already finally chat them out of the
orbital the first over I feel like we'll
walk throughout that got punished don't
watch me and the side step three
beautiful job there chicken you thought
you don't like well I had the adaptation
right if knowing everything was worth -
well but cheaper than just said not I
got this you can tell right now like
Chickering absolutely readjusted each
and every time he's like what do I need
to do to change it up you saw those
openings pay out in dividends you know
that big combo he got right there at the
end and bring him back into the game
that's the chicken we've been seeing all
year yeah he's been seeing these clutch
comebacks and a lot of people look at
geese as that character Chickering plays
well enough he has more character to
back it up where he's done it plenty of
times before no stranger to it oh man
and I'm sure the standings will reflect
that you know now we're gonna have a few
tighter players might pull out and cheek
within both at 1:1 and man this is gonna
be a close one but before we do that we
gotta take a quick break don't go
anywhere we got more pool see action
coming through
[Music]